I have a daughter who's eight and her
brother just turned 18. okay it's my
stepson and this is only a guy thing too
loves to walk by me and act like he's
gonna backhand my ball bag like love
loves it see listen to the laughter in
the room it's Bassy it's basic because
it's only guys that do this [__]
here's the thing every man in here has
either done it or had it done to him
okay and we don't even get mad I know
one time a guy got me so good he was
like poop and I was like
the tape measure I might be six foot for
the only time in my life
oh dude right on the tip it stings
[__] stings I've had dudes do that to
me at the office yeah at work could you
imagine walking into a store and seeing
two women do that to each other
some lady is just like
I got you right in your [__] Cheryl
she wear those lulule weapons on casual
Fridays about backhand that [__] every
Friday Cheryl
hey guys I just want to say thank you so
much my special Lefty son is out and we
are at the time of this recording we're
already over 300 000 views so thank you
so much I appreciate all your support if
you haven't watched it yet I promise you
it's a great watch
um I directed this thing I produced it I
put a lot of time into this thing I was
in the hospital dying and still making
notes on it so go watch it if you
haven't yet share it like it comment on
it get it out there in that algorithm go
support Lefty son it's available my
YouTube now and it is free thank you for
your support
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
guys for for being here again for always
coming back if you haven't subscribed
yet subscribe to the YouTube channel
they keep demonetizing us for every
episode because we talk about real
things and they don't like real words on
YouTube so in order to find us you got
to go find us so hit subscribe that way
it always pops up for you all right if
you gotta have more then you gotta check
out the Honeydew with y'all
it is I'm telling you it's the wildest
show on patreon it's five bucks a month
and
um we just talked to a kid who was in
the classroom of the Michigan State
shooting uh where unfortunately two
students in his class died
um just talked to a double lung
transplant patient and the way he got
the lungs is and what happened is insane
you gotta check this show out I'm
telling you it's staying five bucks and
uh it's every weekend you get the
Honeydew a day early you get an ad free
and you get it at no additional cost and
if you or someone you know has a story
has to be heard please submit it to
honeydew podcast gmail.com and if you're
looking for a new podcast listen to my
old podcast it's an audio only
storytelling podcast with all your
favorites from every podcast you listen
to now it's called The Crab Feast it's
out there subscribe to that alright
uh dates May 26th and May 27th I'll be
in Fort Wayne Indiana June 23rd and 24th
I'll be in Tacoma Washington July 7th
and 8th Appleton Wisconsin July 21st and
22nd Tulsa Oklahoma and make sure you
are watching my special Lefty son on
YouTube all right go get it it's right
there for free on my YouTube channel and
uh that's it now you guys know what we
do over here we highlight the low lights
and you know I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers some
storytellers continue to have stories
behind them and um we're grateful for
that and we're grateful for them being
here and I'm very excited to have this
guest back on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Jason Ellis
welcome back to the Honeydew Jason Ellis
thanks man with the hottest [__]
Salma Hayek shirt
I said to you before like that's the
hottest non-nude scene in filming you
know when I saw that movie I didn't know
that uh anybody turned into a vampire
I'll be either I was just super high me
either I had no idea
it made it so much better when you don't
know vampire yeah yeah she is something
else in that yeah
um here's something else dude thank you
for being here I know we're going to
talk about some [__] today actually is
my 50th birthday we recorded this a few
weeks ago obviously but today's my 50th
birthday and before we talk about that I
want you to plug and promote everything
Jason Ellis oh okay so I have a patreon
um where you know there's a guy on there
talking about bad stuff happening to him
all the time so patreon.com Ellis mate
uh and then I have the Jason Ellis
podcast available everywhere and Hulk
versus wolf it's a podcasts and myself
and Tony Hawk do she's telling you to
come up on the mic she's still there or
at least like angle it up two years ago
yeah so Tony I do a podcast with Tony
Hall called Hulk versus wolf that's
available Everywhere YouTube all that
stuff
um
and I I got Wolf knife's clothing uh
I now have it through another company
not dead yet.com so am I kind of doing a
collaboration with them they make really
good stuff and they were like do you
want to could we make like a wolf knives
collabo and I was like what about if you
just made everything from here on on
and they were like yeah but you'll make
less money and I'm like yeah but your
stuff is good so I don't really I want
good stuff not cheap stuff so it's a
little more expensive but I really love
it now I love wearing it and training in
it so that that's good because I used to
have to get custom t-shirts made of the
t-shirts that I sold because it was
through a company that makes the lowest
grade t-shirt and I'm a t-shirt like I
don't like what the neck is janked or
whatever like I can't live dude like if
you pull that and I know it's janked
like I gotta go you know that one it'll
curl a little bit I'm like nah this is
gone retro t-shirts like oh so bad so
you turn 50 how long ago not too long
ago yeah I'm 51 so a year ago and you
invited me to the party at the time
and uh you rented what a man
so let's talk about your 50th birthday
and let's talk about mine what have you
done so far on your 50th birthday
um so far today yeah I woke up
um I took my daughter to school this
morning happy birthday thank you dropped
her off she wish I could have come to
that that sounds like a party
can't wait to hear yours because I got
invited to this party yeah uh and I did
not go because I had my daughter at the
time and um
I took her to school this made her
breakfast we got ready took her and the
dog dropped my daughter off at school
um I went back to my place did a little
work
um talked to Brandy for a little bit on
the call and then came here other
people's texted me happy birthday I've
been responding to that and then I came
here to to sit with you now that's where
I'm gonna stop because I'm gonna tell
you the rest of what I have after you
tell me how you celebrated your 50th
birthday because I would like to see how
it started right well I got a mansion uh
in Beverly Hills and then I uh I had
four no three girls
and my wife come over to
um
to bang me
for again how many four girls and your
wife no total four girls and me okay
yeah and then a video and a videographer
and a videographer a guy who's just
watching it recording it yeah Sarah that
was weird
uh whose idea was that yours yeah I want
I've always wanted to have a tandem
that's my handsome yeah I wanted to make
a million dollars and have a 10
something is that 10 some you and nine
women yeah okay and then my my first
wife said when you make a million
dollars sure and then I made a million
dollars and she was like no
I didn't think you're gonna make a
million dollars I'm like that's fair
I didn't either
so I was like oh there goes that but
then I got a divorce and then I got
married to someone who's like uh you
know into
doing stuff like that but you could just
never get nine it's hard and I'm 50. not
a lot of people want to sleep with 50
year olds so I get it had you had a a
five some before
um what was the most that's the most
I've had what was the most prior to that
um
foursomes okay yeah so five seven was
something else on the end of that yeah
yeah okay it was a trans girl that was
coming too but she came later so all it
was almost a sixm which would have been
that would have been oh six that would
have been legendary
but anyway I got a little nervous and I
didn't eat all day and I I thought they
were gonna do it and then they didn't do
it and it went until way later in the
day and then when it started they were
like okay go and they're all on the bed
and they're like you just walk in and
you know plow everybody and I'm like
okay and
my dick just didn't really want to
answer it was like too much pressure and
it was kind of up and I was trying to
get it to go up more and
just it just escalated and and then I
was like I'm out
how long did you try
uh I I got I've been the worst part is
there's some guy over there
watching damn no that was half the I was
like man is he filming me now yeah
I
he's zooming in on it it's just such a
bad time
besides sneaking off into the corner and
like eating somebody's butt she'll be
like yeah maybe it'll come back it just
didn't
so how long did you try to get your dick
hard on your five some for your 50th
it's like I did I was in the game for
about 20 and then they finished it off
for the last 15 by themselves and I just
sat there contemplating suicide and then
yeah it said happens don't worry about
it start directing you just tell this
guy like nah I just sat there I was like
it's your birthday try not to get too
depressed about ruining this whole thing
and then they were like we get it some
people you know like when it's cameras
and that many girls it can happen to a
guy we've seen it before who's we who's
saying this all the girls because this
is their their porn girls then yeah okay
they are yeah they're professional all
right they're not just friendly yeah
they're like for how long you've been
involved in stuff like it's a lot you
know like we're not worried about it
and then the trans girl came over and
then I took a boner pill and when she
came over I was back up and running
so I filmed some stuff with her and then
I think there was a little bit of a
conversation about how gay Jason is
potentially and then at the end of the
night I was told
I'm just laughing because of my birthday
because it was really cool all these
things were really cool but it was also
um like I was told that maybe you're gay
and I was like you're gonna say that on
my birthday you are because you're the
only one that really knows me who's
saying this my wife or your wife
and you know the next day she was like I
was drunk I didn't mean it but
it did something to me for sure it
offended you
it shouldn't offend me but yeah I
thought you liked men yeah but I'm
mainly straight okay but
I think I've been getting a lot gayer
lately
I feel like I just didn't know myself
dude I've just like I would never I did
stuff with guys every now and then
and it was very hedro like I was you can
suck it but you're not kissing me like
you know there's certain things that I
won't do okay because it's too gay we
touched on a little bit no I didn't mean
that in that way but last time we talked
about this but we didn't go there so
kissing is off what else is off limits
well it's not anymore okay well before
raging homo before you get to being a
raging homo before what were your sort
of rules you just suck it don't put your
face in my face you know there's no
cuddling or [__] no no I'm not hugging
you at all no
because I love you
and I've got past it all now good but at
the time I'm not gay but I hug the [__]
out of you yeah well I'm not
it's a different hug you know it is a
different hug it's like after you burn
and then they want to like spoon it's
like dude you're crazy
but now I can because you know you are
I know who I am a little bit more now
and it does well hold on a second you
took the boner pill got fired up for the
trans girl then it becomes how gay is
Jason maybe you're gay yeah do you think
that happens to your dick if you don't
take the boner pill
I was out for the day if I didn't take
that Bona pill it wouldn't have got up
so then if I should have taken one right
yeah or something yeah or even when it
didn't work I'd have been like just give
me a minute here yeah everybody eat
[__] up give me 40 minutes that's I
didn't have the courage to say that I
was like everyone's going I I'll just
move out I'll move out it was really bad
I'm surprised I'm so me too because but
if you don't take this pill your dick
doesn't get hard so you also don't [__]
the trans girl then you don't even have
the whole conversation of how gay is
Jason yeah yeah that would have been
better yeah so what bothered you about
your wife saying that
because I had to contemplate that it
might be true and that's what bothered
you yeah
and so that's where you spend your 50th
birthday contemplating like am I if
you're gay and how gay are yeah am I
yeah
okay can I finish my birthday my videos
you're obviously going somewhere to
party after this right
right after this
today at two o'clock I'm going to look
at a new uh apartment or home or
whatever over here in this area trying
to get closer to my daughter's
neighborhood because it's outrageously
expensive okay and uh so was this
Hospital stay and I'm gonna go do that
and then I'm gonna pick her up at school
and I'm gonna take her to dance class
and I'm gonna sit at dance class where
there's a jacket that says dance dad
that she wants me to get and I'm like
nah I bought her and her friend Jackets
last week dance jackets I paid in
everybody's mouths and everybody paid in
mine
oh
very different birthday right very
different after dance class I'm taking
her to her mom's and I'm gonna go home
and maybe I have dinner with Dan Van
Kirk tonight and maybe I just [__]
lay on the couch and watch the new
Mandalorian and that's my 50th [__]
birthday dude wow now in my defense I
know I I've never been a birthday guy
I've never been a dude I've never have I
mean I've been with plenty of women
where at work or whatever too where
we'll go to a place and not one of them
will say this place is cute I'm gonna
have my birthday here I've that's never
been a sentence come out of my mouth I
think I'll have my birthday here has
never been a sentence I've uttered right
I don't look at a venue when I walk in
as a place I may come back to celebrate
with friends outside of if it's a
restaurant I'll bring you because I like
this place we're gonna go eat sushi here
okay we're not gonna throw a festive
event here right I've def I mean why
don't you celebrate your birthday I
don't know I don't know you're too manly
to do it but but I'm not you know what I
mean I'm really not I have I have this
is such a super yeah no I'm a ego guy
like you don't like anti the ego right
so that's so celebrating your birthday
is a little egotistical yeah you know
when someone goes Fair it's my birthday
week you're like weeks it's not week
thank you you don't get to say weeks but
then enough people around me said it
where I was like I'm having a birthday
week well after you have a near-death
experience too you start to think about
[__] like that like Okay so this this
50th birthday
it's it hasn't lost its shine in the
sense that I'm so glad to be here for
another one but but 51 it's going to be
way more important than 50 now and 52's
gonna you know what I'm saying so this
this nice round number of 50 is awesome
I'm glad I made it here but as far as
the way I was looking at it before I
almost died and the way I'm looking at
it after two different [__] ways 53
is my pressure cooker that's when my dad
died so if I make it to 54 I beat him
yeah so that's not a 42. and I almost
died at 42. that's when I first
discovered I had these clots and
everything exactly at that time wow same
way same everything now I hit 50. I'm
trying to get 53 more years out of this
[__] computer right here I mean
you've told the story on here already
right yes it has air by now yeah because
you told me today and I'm like dude as a
person that's had
health problems where they're like
you're having a heart attack and you
sent me flowers and everything dude yeah
and an eye mask
I did that you thought was funny and
that was came in so [__] handy I
sweat through the other one I had I saw
it
I was like I really did love it dude
thank you good no worries
yeah
but yeah it was a scary thing and uh now
um you know I wanted to go on a vacation
I still can't fly yet my back's still
[__] up you know my lungs still have
clots but I'm I'm okay with like they
just have to go away so it's all good
but did you have a five some would I
could you right now hell no no they'd
break me in half dude okay they break me
and I would be listen I could have the
one you had
finished
[Music]
I just was thinking I was gonna be the
champion this back right now dude I
promise you that there's no fives coming
out of here but not once if I thought
I like to piss in somebody's mouth on my
50th birthday that's a thought that
doesn't cross my mind yeah I'm pissing
mine hadn't thought of it I don't know
that I've met women and here's the other
thing see that's the other thing I
wonder I've been around big drink is a
lot
like in the last five to six years the
amount of pee that has crossed my mouth
and everybody else that I hang out with
this is definitely a demonetized oh man
it's cares who cares they all are sorry
everybody out there is making money on
YouTube I'm not making [__] on YouTube
they demonetize almost every episode
what is that
it's just life you know
um I wonder I wonder how many women like
because you dated a girl in high school
she's not into whatever she's into in
high school yet she who knows where they
go or in a guy too who knows what
they've evolved into
um so I wonder maybe sure maybe
somewhere in the my past there was a pea
drinker but I I didn't get the
opportunity right I only have one girl
that wanted me to pee on her
um and I peed on her in the shower that
was it her leg it was not you know
that's a starter kit it's a starter kit
that's exactly what that is it
progresses yeah
but you the thing I love about you is
you're a [__] man like I saw the clip
of you and Dr Drew Where you said if we
were walking down the street and you
just ran up the two strangers and said
which one of us is gay it's definitely
different and it is it is he looks gay
as hell that's what Society thinks
though yeah and what I love about you is
that you're every bit of [__] man but
you're unashamed of who you are and
you're still learning well you're still
learning who you really are right more
and more we all are hopefully if you're
really working on yourself but I wish
and Aaron Rodgers uh a [__] like uh
Patrick Mahomes some
body on a level
LeBron or whatever will come out and be
like no I'm gay yeah no you're not
really gay no no I [__] I [__] men
and I am gay as [__] and I love it
there's no way statistically you take
the entire NFL
with all those men on every [__] team
and the NBA and tell me there's not one
gay guy in that group [__] [__]
it's not this is not statistically
possible there's no way I'm the only one
there's no way you know like I'm just
the only guy that is into
like manly stuff and blown dudes like no
it's just a thing that if you're like me
and you live in this area of
influence it's not a good idea to say
you do that well people get bummed out
yeah it goes it follows you because the
Sports you chose
skateboarding I remember you telling me
especially back then it wasn't it was
not cool to be gay in skateboarding and
you were harassed MMA is another sport
that I feel like it's probably not a
great idea to be yeah one guy wore the
rainbow shirts and the amount of heat he
took for wearing shorts that had a
rainbow on it
it scared me when I saw all the people
saying stuff I was like
note to self you [__] up
and now you're in comedy entertainment
podcasting whatever again not an
environment that you feel
you feel the same way you feel it's is
it's on Parallel to uh the skateboarding
days in the MMA days worse same no I
don't think it's bad at all oh you don't
I think sometimes like when you said
Appleton Wisconsin I did a gig there and
I think my comedy like I kind of have a
lot I have like a a like 20 18 minute
bit about being gay that was more like
two minutes in Appleton
yeah because I had this feeling that
people were like what not dude you know
and I was like oh okay so it's not
everywhere but comic wise I don't think
anybody hates me for
talking about that stuff I have I
haven't caught it where someone's like
really dude that's what you're gonna
talk about
only fans that that are old school fans
when I was totally straight and they
feel let down
and I get it I understand it really you
have fans who feel let down that you are
not who you were then or you don't [__]
who you used to [__] then they still do
I just added some people to my list when
was the first
um homosexual experience you had that
you wanted to have
yeah that's tough what age because there
were two boys when I was young that just
blew me out of nowhere that were my
friends and I'm like what the hell one
guy in a Jacuzzi how old
17 and then another time when I was like
14 I had a skateboard buddy and he just
started blowing me in his room and his
mum came in no yeah and saw it for sure
like I flipped around or whatever and he
tried to like
spin around but you know when you're a
parent and you open the door and two
kids are doing something they shouldn't
it was when I think about it now I'm
like she totally saw it did she say
anything no just shut the door yeah just
whoa okay you guys need some lunch or
something uh and he was like your son's
getting a pound
this one's getting a mouthful now man
so I don't think I ever went for one
until I was uh
probably 30s
when oh wow I took a bunch of ecstasy
and I'd been to a gay club before and
when I took it I just didn't want to
hang out with my friends and I left and
went there and then uh a big guy who was
a cross-dresser real big had heels on
but he was probably like a 280 guy and
you know the big hair and stuff so he
looked like he was seven feet tall and
he was just eyeing me out at the bar and
then he came over and he's like hey man
let me let me blow you and I was like
okay
but I agree to that
that was first time someone asked
permission and first time you said okay
all right and then
the convenience of it being such a
horndog where somebody just blows you
and says thank you and leaves
that was hard not to go back there
listen
I I know that being gay is a it's in
your fiber it's in your DNA it's in your
makeup it's who you are and I know that
because I can't tell you
how enticing
a [__] can I suck your dick yup bang
bang I'm out of here never see you again
thank you so much sounds yeah I just
can't get past the fact that it's a man
doing it and that's how I know gay is
not a choice right that's how you know I
have a bit in my stand-up where it's
like if you're if nobody existed and no
one was gonna point you out for doing
something wrong and some guy was just
saying hey man let me blow you in I'm
out of here just I just want you to
finish that's it
I mean how bad is a [__] it's it's
usually pretty good and and I hate to
say it but guys are their level of
[__] it's usually better
ah is it come on do they know dicks but
do you feel like women eat [__] better
than two of them because they they know
[__] yep they know theirs
on average yeah
so a male blow job in your experience
has been better than a female [__]
I mean there's a couple girls out there
that you're like whoa you know where did
you learn yeah how long you been doing
that guys it's just they all because
it's just how much you like doing it too
I think like a good [__] is someone
who enjoys giving it yeah I wouldn't
feel like okay guys but also women are
very every woman is different like some
are coming clitorally some are coming
vaginally some are coming anally some
are coming all of them summer squirting
some of this a guy if you just grab it
and grip it and you move it up and down
eventually yep you can figure it out
pretty quick so it's it's it it's all
you gotta do it's a it's a really cool
scene if you're me
you know because once I got past
everybody's opinion of it
it's what I am it's what I like to do
opinion of what of you being with men
yeah
because it hurts you know did you keep
it quiet for a while oh yeah you did
yeah I wasn't sure what I was I was like
maybe you just
dude why do you say so when you say what
I was are you talking about
gay straight and not just being a person
like being gay or straight and is it
confusing because it's not defined for
someone like you meaning you like to
[__] everything it just didn't add up
that I would be gay it didn't make any
sense to you yeah okay
and I grew up in a way where if you're
gay there's something wrong with you
so I think I just denied it well we're
the same age pretty much and even when I
grew up like
it didn't matter what you did I I can't
play sports today guys I have a cold
it's fun queer over here yeah everything
I said that to people everything was
being yeah yeah yeah I was one of the
worst ones yeah oh come on homo like
just get up [__] suck it up let's go
yeah
yeah so I think I kind of accidentally
talked myself into being
the complete opposite of what I am
so do you think then that you Dove
literally into women to overcompensate
for that or to bury that or hide that or
did you not think that no I definitely
didn't think that so you do really you
do enjoy sex with women yeah okay it
just seems like lately
I might be gay are you surprised that in
your 50s you're coming to that now or is
it not a surprise no it's devastating
why why is this episode I don't need to
make my life any harder you know yeah
it's already hard enough and now I'm
doing this to people you know like
people are hurt you know hurt by you
being gay yeah
why I mean I I don't think my wife
you know is would prefer if I was a bit
you know I've got gear over the years
and I don't know if she's that into it
yeah so I hurt her because I was
something and now I'm something
different same with the fans like
you're selling one thing and now you're
another well what were you selling
before that you aren't now being a
Mindless heterosexual like aggressive
Alpha
[__]
and now I'm the same thing but you're
not heterosexual
well no it's changed my opinion of a lot
of stuff like I don't know I'm a bit
more of a libtard like I don't I feel
like uh you know people trying to ban
drag queens and stuff is just like maybe
20 years ago I wouldn't have
reacted to it but now I'm like what is
wrong with you why are we doing this to
people what is a Tran what is your
aggressions towards trans people I think
you got to know them you know because to
me I have a lot of
um non-binary and trans friends and I
know them I love them I love the person
that they are and I see how Society
hurts them and I feel bad for them you
know if I do it I still do it to them
where I go yeah how you know how's she
going and and someone will go how are
they gone and I go ah you know and my
friend is like it's been like five years
Jason and I'm like you know I got this
dumb man brain but if you're a trans so
here's where I get ignorant too if
you're a trans woman you're not a she
I don't know that stiff if you're a
trans woman is if you're a trans man
which means you're born a lady and now
you're a man you're not a he yeah they
get Top surgery they take uh
testosterone and they became they get
jacked and they get a lot manly their
voice gets deeper all that stuff they're
a man calling them a man or you know me
mate or you know him yeah it's not
offense that's all they want okay so
it's not that hard for me to say that
then what are you saying she that's
offensive that should be a there these
are the see those ones were easy for me
to figure out like if you're a trans
girl which means born a guy and now
you're a girl you're a girl that's all
you want to be it was easy for me okay
especially when you look like
ridiculously hot lady it's not hard but
then there's non-binary so I have
friends that are born a woman
that are not they didn't take
testosterone they might have like a
shorter haircut or some something a
little different but just a hot chick
who is non-binary so they're they them
and the they them to a really cute girl
that when I first met them they were a
girl and now I have to do the they them
or or or or they want to be he
so it's hard to adjust to that stuff but
I just know well especially if you know
him first and what well okay so that
I've been calling somebody I hear him
for 10 years and now they're him and I
go hey man how do you think he should
also give a little leeway to people well
that see that's not a lot the one that
I'm talking about is way cooler with
I'll be like I've stumbled several times
and they go I don't even care honestly
but her partner
they them partner
ikatsu
you know and I and I I care for her and
I really would prefer to say something
that she likes to hear that's all and
when everyone gets angry about it and we
gotta stop them I just think of her when
I see it and I go man I wonder how they
feel when they're watching this you know
okay they're just like we're Banning
gays you know I'd be like wait do I um
am I getting deported for a sucking a
dick
is that what's coming it's coming down
to because it's not I didn't forcefully
blow anyone like they were like can you
blow me
so apparently you can forcefully [__]
kids and everything and still be a
comedian
you know you can rape people and still
be a comedian am I wrong I don't think I
am from what I've heard no you're not
apparently you can do whatever the [__]
you want still be a comedian it sounds
like I don't want to be in this ever
have those nights where the day plays on
repeat over and over and that leaves the
next morning a drag dag grass has you
covered to calm those bedtime
ruminations so you can fall asleep fast
and stay snoozing until morning dagrass
is legal organic smokable hemp that
relaxes your body and Mellows your mind
they're 100 organic pre-rolled joints
and flour are very low in THC and high
in CBD so you can enjoy the effects of
CBD while keeping a clear head you're
not looking to tote digress offers the
finest tinctures and gummies on the
market all the Mellow goodness no smoke
required all digress products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the U.S whether you're looking for a new
Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite dad grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now that grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to daggrass.com honeydew for
20 percent off your first order that's
daggrass.com
honeydew our next partner is athletic
greens I heard about athletic greens and
decided to give them a try because I
wanted to improve my gut health and get
my immune system a little extra support
plus I wanted a supplement that actually
tastes good it's all your key Health
Products like multivitamins minerals pre
and probiotics and more working together
as one I added ag1 to my morning routine
and it really does leave me feeling like
I'm doing something good for my body it
gives me the nutrients I need you know
it makes me feel good about myself it's
made with 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients that deliver benefits like
mood immune and sleep support sustained
energy and so much more you can even get
an inconvenient travel packs for you on
the go like I'm using for my upcoming
tour so if you want to take ownership of
your health today is a good time to
start athletic greens is giving you a
free free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
honeydew that's athleticgreens.com
honeydew check it out now let's get back
to the dupe
um
I want to learn this too you say you're
getting gayer you're you might be gay
you're 53
um
what's going on with that
it's harder sure but are you not doing
anything about it you're a [__] man
with a sex drive so how you handling
that
um
yeah I don't know I feel like
it's really hard I feel I don't know if
I can date a man I don't know
I don't know if I could date anyone I
feel bad for anybody that dates me why
because I'm always
um you know trying to Bone somebody
trying to what have sex
with guys and girls all the time
so then why do you want to be married
well I thought we had an open
relationship but I feel like it's kind
of got to the point where I'm going too
far and she's the opposite now she's
less into all that stuff and I can't
stop it it's like what I'm it's what I
want to be that would make me happy like
I go to work and then at night I get
laid
with anybody do you believe in an open
marriage now after having one
yeah I but if you're not that's what I'm
saying things have changed what she
really wants and what I really want are
two different things people grow apart
like sure it doesn't have to also they
people change they don't necessarily
grow apart they just change that's like
I'm into this now but I'm not because I
love her I will always love her but I
feel bad for her being around me now
you feel bad yeah like she wants to
break up with me and I kind of don't
blame her
so it's
it's really bad man I can't believe I'm
here
so then how do you
it's a tough question I guess like
if you guys get a divorce
and you feel now that you're a gay man
do you ever [__] women again do you ever
date women again or if you're a gay man
are you just men now no no I really so
then is that not not gay like what I
don't understand
isn't that what's it called when you uh
pop uh not poly um it might see I might
be more like that is that Polly when you
because you say you'll [__] anything is
what you always
I jokingly say this but I'm saying is
that what poly someone whose poly is is
well then you now you have or is that a
relationship people you have
relationships with more polyamorous is
more than one person okay both of them
was more like you can sleep with anybody
as long as you get permission but what
is it when you don't care you love men
pansexual thank you pansexual that's yes
but that's different than gay yeah are
there men and women who are like no I
just like women I just like men I just
feel like if you like men a lot and
you're still pan
it's hard for a girl to date that person
I see okay it's a lot of pressure on
them and it's not fair
so what are you what is it actually
you're thinking are you thinking that
you wouldn't have sex with women anymore
just men no everybody's still on the
list so though
so then why are you saying you might be
gay uh just more gay than I've ever been
and I told you it's harder for a woman
you can't date me
Anna
it's not it's too much for unless the
woman also wants to do that
but in your experience women want to be
in relationships I mean I've met Paulie
people but I've never dated one no and I
just I feel bad if I really am getting
divorced like I'm
I don't want to put myself on anyone you
know
I think at this point
also maybe it's a good time for you to
be single right now and also maybe
you're just more into guys now maybe
it's two years and then all of a sudden
you're into whatever the hell else
you're into over there maybe it's trans
ladies after that yeah just that for a
while who knows yeah
I doubt it but you've had sex with trans
ladies and trans men I was gonna ask the
other way yes and trans men what do you
find yourself more attracted to the
trans ladies or the trans men
uh I mean
it depends on your look you know but
there's some really hot trans men that
they kind of make sense to me because I
you know I like vaginas
and I and I like the manly part too so a
man with a vagina or a man who used to
be a man it's not a woman with a vagina
right oh well that's the full surgery
that's oh that's it because if you're a
transsexual you're usually a lady with a
penis oh you do still keep the penis
your actual penis yeah yep and then
there's uh wait stop there translate so
we've got breast and a penis yep are is
the penis in play during sex time or do
they just want to be a lady not
everybody but it depends it depends yeah
sometimes it's very obvious that they
don't want you to treat them like a man
and then some of them have raging boners
and wanna
you know poke you with it
also they don't want to just some trans
girls or tops
and they just want to be the top
which is
it's interesting this is an eye open
it's a lot of openings I mean if your
butt works like that you know what about
the other way
um
uh with a vagina can you penetrate that
vagina do they have
uh orgasms and feelings can you act and
it works for a used to be a man and now
has a vagina and it works yeah really
yeah I had a threesome with one with
Katie and I
big black girl huge ass but she's full
had to full up she had a vagina
now what about the other way women with
a penis yeah well it depends on how long
they've been doing it yeah yeah if they
take testosterone and they have from
like a you know like uh 18 to 40 they're
gonna have a a big [__] because it
makes their [__] turn into a penis oh I
see okay so I've seen like muscle uh
building videos yeah where they showed
the [__] and it looked like the head of
a dick it really did yeah and now they
were like well that's the penis so if
you take a difference then they'll get
actually grow like you lick it like a
vagina but you also suck the little
penis
sorry
I learned so much on this show I don't
know how much of it I need to know
moving forward I'm gonna check out my
patreon you guys there's plenty more
definitely some nuggets of uh knowledge
on this goddamn show all right but
you're just attracted right now to
men born men that's what you mean by you
being gay or lately what do you mean by
that no well if I'm trying to at the
stop my gayness was very I'm a straight
guy and I don't get I had little issues
with it like I didn't feel comfortable
hugging a guy in that way
maybe feel uncomfortable so now I'm you
know like I have a friend who's I've
been seeing for
like you know like seven years or
something I love him and I'll hug the
[__] out of that guy
but that never was the case for the
longest time so it just
you know being like bottoming for guys
and stuff I don't think a lot of girls
think that's a turn on
that's fine
but I also don't
want to bomb anybody out especially
somebody I really care about I don't
want to make them feel like I'm gross do
you think that
most straight women don't want to date a
man who's even bisexual they just don't
want any part of any man or man yes they
just want a man to be with them
it was just fun
it's normal but I don't understand what
it what is it you're looking for in
marriage then that you
if it's not exclusivity with this one
person is it exclusive to emotions like
are you is everyone else just uh needs
to be scratched I've ruined it this is
all my fault dude like I I talk to
people I start sleeping with them and
then I have feelings for them and now
they're my friend and I love them and we
bone and it's not fair to Katie
Oh you mean that's what you would do
during your open relationship it
happened a couple times
and then you get friendly to them
they're not just a one-off and often to
the night you go right because the is
that what well I started to do that type
of relationship to me it was healthier
to just have sex with somebody you don't
really care for is not good so I changed
and now I have like a few regulars and
that's all I see I don't see randoms
anymore because there's too many STDs
out there and I want to bring it home
so I only try to hook up with people
that I can trust that get tested and all
that stuff so let me ask it this way
then you've got these few regulars
they're satisfying your sexual needs
yeah what is it about the marriage what
is it about the wife that's different
what is it that you wanted out of that
that you're that these holes you're
filling are being filled by are not
fulfilling
um
I
I thought I had a teammate that was into
exactly what I was into like the reason
I came out in the first place is because
Katie was like are you bi and I was like
maybe she's like oh it's so hot not I'll
put up with it it was hot
but I think now that it's flourishing
it's hard to deal with me you know like
I could burn her and then later that
night I'm trying to get boned
too much
you know I feel
but it's what I want
so it's like what do I do
and and uh you know now she's like I'm
she's sick of me for doing stuff like
this liking photos of people I'm not
supposed to be talking to I'm a
nightmare you know and I can't help it
I don't it's like what I what I want I
think I'm scared of being alone
you know I've always tried to lean on
somebody because I feel like uneducated
and I can't like buy things with my
credit card or my phone because I don't
know how to like do you know I'm pretty
childish
um and I just you know I had a partner
that was
T we were together on this and now I
feel like I've gone I'm putting stress
on her that she doesn't deserve you know
because she lets me do more than
I don't know anybody else it has that
I've heard say my wife is like yeah go
to sleep with that guy and that girl and
have a fivesome I'll help organize it
you know yeah and then to be like no I
need more dude this is all your fault
how would you feel when you're would
your wife partake in sleeping with other
men and women without you the way you
did without her and how do you feel
about that
um depends sometimes I'll be a bit
jealous but I knew that it was right
because I was doing it
because she's not what
um the thing that she would not like is
that the emotional connection and
obviously for her to hook up with a guy
she needs to really care for them she's
not gonna just let anybody put it in so
I get that but when I started copying
her in that way
because I sleep with I want to sleep
with people all week you know there's
two people yeah she wants us she might
sleep with a guy like once a year
so it's not the same
like my drive is
is higher but you also have a man's
testosterone Drive yes I've I've read a
few things and again I'm very ignorant
but I've read a few things about
trans
if you go from a lady to a man you're a
trans man correct
the testosterone once they get it it
I've seen a couple of things where
people women have been like hey I'm
sorry like I didn't know this [__]
affected you like that yeah like to go
from zero testosterone and then have a
healthy dose pumped into immediately
they're usually pretty horny yeah I'll
bet yeah oh [__] bad yeah they become
more like us yeah super horny yeah I'll
bet they are
just cool
depends on who you are but yeah so now
what do you do what's next then oh man I
just try to be grateful that I'm still
alive and I'm not going to hospital for
any heart problems or anything but it's
tough man okay I find it hard to sleep
now
I'm worried about my future like a
career and
and relationship like am I just gonna be
living in an apartment by myself
am I going to be okay with that you know
like it's all it's all up in the air
right now so
I'm scared
what scares you most
being alone
yeah I have
any family really
and then Katie was it you know
so that scares the [__] out of me
to be honest
but it it's probably for the best
for her for her yeah what's best for you
that she's uh is wants to come and uh
have sex with me with all these people
and I can talk to anybody I want and say
whatever I want to them and they can say
whatever they want to me I'm just not
leaving her you know
but it is not fair I I know that and
that's why I'm not trying to no no you
don't understand I'm like you totally
understand you might understand it more
than me because I'm just going you know
especially now else meaning getting
canceled and all these
Lewis dropping out of fights and then
the guy that I let go on the show
the the band that we were supposed to
get back together people didn't want to
do the band anymore because they let go
of that guy just one thing after another
just boom boom boom boom and I'm like
dude I was
the second biggest show on Sirius XM
what happened
It's like because you're being you
you've changed and people don't relate
to it as much
but I am being me you know that's the
thing that I am addicted to is the more
I find out things about myself that I I
wanna get past it and move on because
it's a surprise to me all these things
that
the way I think I didn't think I would
ever think like this so
I think it's best that I stay away from
people in that manner because
I'm gonna break your heart
I don't know dude I've been a negative
it's hard to have a positive outlook oh
I know this it's also hard to because
it's such a sticky [__] situation
with so many literal ins and outs in
this goddamn thing here you want a
partner who
we'll be there and let you do whatever
you want to do whenever you want to do
it also join in on it whenever you want
let you like photos you shouldn't like
and talk to people you shouldn't talk to
and everything but what is that why what
that's not a partner though no you're
right Nobody's Gonna Want You wouldn't
want that right
no I'm probably uh better off being by
myself and having a couple of people
that I see I was gonna say if you had
four people you consistently see it I
mean is that enough for you for now to
at least help you through whatever it is
you're going through next and then see
if you can find another partner and then
and then go ahead but I don't think I
should find another partner I was gonna
say and then if you do even find another
partner
does the partner you want is that are
they really allowed to do whatever you
do well here's the thing that and do you
want me to say woman might be more gay
because you know who would be down for
that a dude yep that's what I just said
I said next one gonna be a woman or a
man a guy would be a 100 down people
like this is the greatest idea ever oh
my God
and I still feel weird about like living
with a guy that's okay
[Laughter]
I'm so dirty and [__] like come on and
I'm so tough dude it's like you just got
back from the gym and then we're like
hey babe what's for dinner to a dude
like dude you're so gay
so yeah
that's it that's who's gonna love that
right yeah and he's gonna be like I got
three more of me just like me right over
here that would be pretty cool it never
hit me
like I have a friend of mine out in Palm
Springs gay guy and um we'd always go
out and visit him and [__] and then he
would tell me about the gay parties they
throw and he's like oh Ryan after the
white party you know the white party
yeah yeah it's the big party in Palm
Springs is that like Diddy's thing no
this is like the did he start it I don't
know who started but this is like the
the gay bash oh oh this is the ball
yeah you would love to go I would love
to go on a gay crew they'd love to have
you there yeah
um
but he would say like they do after
parties back at his place and
everybody'd be Milling around and
drinking or whatever
and they would hire
a shower
you know dicks got Growers and showers
yep
they would hire a shower who had that
[__] dong down to the knees but he
would be like the cook so he would have
to grill the food bucknake and
everything and then he walks and serves
and everybody's grabbing it and touching
it and [__] you know what I mean I love
those putties and then he shows me
grinder at the time this is years ago
and I didn't know what grind he's like
oh this is for dudes for dudes oh yeah
right at least at that time it was I
don't know what it is now I go um show
me some of the profile pictures let me
show me because you want to see my
favorite one and this is when I was like
dudes are [__] pigs and it yeah
so the profile pic you know you you have
to be a friend with this guy to unlock
it to see his dick pics and all yeah not
this guy this guy's pick profile pic was
his [__] gaping [__] and you had
to friend request it to see the cheese
you can't do that
you get reported for that nutmeg then
okay this is years ago and I'm telling
you I was like dude I get I got one for
you I get it and I got one for you
there's this guy I know he's got like a
glory hole in his house and he's like in
his house yeah you're also allowed to
come to his house yeah but still you're
coming to his home yeah any lunatic
what no he's a friend of mine no but I
mean if he's got a glory hole aren't
randos coming up and putting their names
it's in his house okay you gotta go into
his house and he's got one installed in
his room got it but it's a problem like
a door and everything but he's a kinky
guy and he's into fisting and all this
stuff and every now and then he'd ask me
like do you want to come over and watch
me do some stuff and I was like yeah
because I don't know about any of it and
I don't care anymore what you think so
yeah I want to see it but uh he's like I
got this guy coming over who uh has a
lot of injections and I'm like
injections in what do you mean he's like
oh he has really big balls in a huge ass
covered in tribal like his whole back
his whole body is covered in this really
bad 80s tribal big black stuff and he's
got like a ridiculous butt like a butt
implant where it's just like why would
you do that and he's got his penis and
his balls injected with
is it saline or I don't know what I
don't know but his balls are this big no
and his penis doesn't get hot it's just
like a it just sits fat yeah like a
[__] thermos yeah
and you just you know slap him around
chug him and deep like speed bag is not
like is that what he wants they're big
so you can punch him and do that into
his butt
no I did one two no one two one two one
two in it yeah
it's okay to
get okay okay bro with the gay sex
escalates yeah it's a double fizzy but
you don't need to start there you don't
say you don't need to stop no no I can't
do that yeah
dude if I see you with an ejected ass at
the comedy store or something I'm gonna
be like nah that could be my gimmick
it might be the one four people from the
audience
everybody's gonna take punch in your ass
punching my ass yeah it's funny I might
write that down now I'm not ready to
take that yet he told me another story
of a guy came over that he knew there
was like a fisting Champion as well
Champion dude he told me about it
people have reports on how good their
butts are like it's like a people give
them star ratings like if you want to
fist my ass I'm telling you this is a
good one yeah no it's a Yelp for your
[__] get the [__] out of here I think
this is gay guys thought of August I
don't know anyway he had a guy come over
there and seen for a long time and he
had a baby a rubber baby
that you put in people's butts and he
was like do you want to try the rubber
baby I haven't tried it on anyone yet
and he was like yeah and I guess he put
it in newborn he put it in there and he
was holding it and for some weird reason
it just went no and sucked out of his
hand and went in there
and they couldn't get it out and the guy
was freaking out and they try to like
use warm towels or something he said but
it got to the point where like we can't
we have to go to the hospital and he was
so freaked out that he had to go to
hospital for having a baby in his
stomach and then they gave him a
C-section no no
a fake baby caused the real C-section he
had a baby
got a baby needless to say they are not
friends anymore
he didn't get to see the baby he doesn't
get visited right I think he wanted to
see the baby actually
seems like a bad diet that is crazy dude
right that's crazy that's where I was
like that is crazy
but it's interesting
God that is come on is that real yes
whatever kitty litter
dude you're a wild [__] I didn't
do that no but you know the stories uh
and thank you for sharing them thank you
for always coming back and being so open
and honest I can see and feel the
genuine pain and confusion I I
will make it different 50th we're having
a different 50th birthdays today yeah
happy birthday dude thank you I hope
it's a good one thank you I love stoked
you here I love you I'm glad I'm here
too dude um again thank you for doing
this as always in plug promote whatever
you'd like please just check the Jason
Alice show out we really need it uh Hulk
versus wolf it's a good show you know
we've got Undertakers and
Seth rogans and all kinds of celebrities
on there and then the patreon we do
three Jason Ellis shows a week on there
and then I do two uh solo shows so it's
five shows a week and audio is like five
bucks and I think for
for all the shows and videos 15 but
we do a lot of stuff on there it's a
good show we work hard check it out go
check it out support it as always I am
Ryan sickler Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all your social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]